hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
Guiding clinical laboratory integration
of next-generation sequencing to assure
quality testing presented by ira women
he's a senior scientist within the
division of laboratory systems at the
Center for Disease Control and
Prevention and a clinical molecular
geneticist certified by American Board
of Medical Genetics I am Marjorie
Torrance of blaggards and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Latins
lab roots is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many of your
questions as you have time for at the
end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble see or hear in the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and those offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. IRA
Rubin I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello everyone really appreciate the
opportunity to speak today about guiding
clinical laboratory integration of
next-generation sequence to assure
quality testing today I'm going to talk
about a number of topics that include
the excitement that remains and is
growing regards to next-generation
sequencing and its implementation in the
clinical setting going to spend a few
minutes talking about the integration of
next-generation sequencing into the
clinical laboratory the majority of the
talk I'm going to to speak about
assuring quality practices through the
application of regulatory requirements
and professional guidance and I'm going
to complete the talk by saying a few
words about generating a clinical
clinically meaningful results so to
begin the excitement behind
next-generation sequence really comes
down to the capability of being able to
sequence large regions of the human
genome and pathogen sequencing and in
this diagram here this describes our
evolution from moving with the
capability of traditional sequence
analysis Sanger sequencing where we had
the capability in a single reaction to
sequence upwards to 800 base pairs
sometimes a little bit more to where we
can now sequence larger regions of the
genome that includes panels made up of
multiple genes the exome the exo-m is
the coding region of the genome that
includes around 180,000 exons which
represents one percent of the genome or
the majority of the human genome upwards
to 3 billion bases and as one moves from
smaller to larger regions of the journey
the complexity of the analysis increases
and we'll talk more about this further
than to the talk so NGS has literally
taken off in the last in the last ten
years and it's applications continue to
grow we're seeing applications in the
diagnosis of Arella tere diseases cancer
diagnosis prognosis treatment selection
carrier screening pathogen
identification and discovery microbiome
analysis and Public Health outbreak
responses some of the Sentinel reports
over the recent years are represented on
this slide and the first making it
definitive diagnosis published from the
Medical College of Wisconsin was the
first that really showed the power of
next-generation sequence describing a
child that presented with chrome-like
syndrome had what was appeared obviously
a heritable condition but was entrancing
into any traditional clinical workup or
test in terms of making a diagnosis to
provide a way forward to save the
child's life exome analysis resulted in
the finding of a single immune gene
associated variant the provided
confidence to provide bone marrow stem
cell transplant that saved the child's
life other areas that have been reported
applications of DNA based liquid biopsy
for central nervous system neoplasms is
a report that looks at glioblastoma and
the power of next-generation sequencing
to provide a genetic profile for a
complex tumor which is a sentinel
component of the process being able to
develop and assess interventions that
target then target a wide set of
subpopulations of tumor cells that are
that contribute to the cancer and
provide a real hope for providing an
effective cure
the not-too-distant future and being
able to sequence large regions of the
genome oftentimes well many times I
should say findings are found that are
not initially looked for but have health
consequences for the patients these are
called secondary findings and this was
recognized by many in the field of
genetics and the American College of
medical genetics assembled a group to
identify those secondary findings that
should be reported allowing patients who
are having genomic sequence for whatever
indication for testing to understand
that there were these other findings
that have health implications several of
these for example are targeted to
heritable cancers that permit
surveillance to be put in place and
early detection of cancer affording the
greatest opportunity for a truck
effective treatment and cure the next
report whole genome sequencing and
social network analysis of a
tuberculosis outbreak New Brunswick
Canada several years ago reported in
2011 was a case where whole genome
sequencing which is the same as
next-generation sequencing was used to
identify to discover that there were two
strains evolved from a single strain
that were actually responsible for the
transmission pattern that was observed
and this data together with what was
referred to a social network analysis or
identifying where contacts were made
within the affected population really
gave a very clear definition about what
was happening interesting here it was
expected that a whole genome sequencing
was not utilized the existence of two
strains probably would not have been
detected which raises the question in
terms of how many times this has
happened in previous types
outbreaks in which there may have been
more than one strain that went
undetected and the new one of the the
newer and exciting areas of research is
the microbiome and these are the
bacteria that that inhabit our gut and
other areas of the body that that modify
and you know modulate chronic diseases
and infections in in terms of disease
progression and other aspects and
next-generation sequencing gives us the
capability of genetically profiling and
understanding how the microbiome
contributes to disease pathogenicity
providing a new entree into developing
interventions as is the case for
Clostridium difficile infection as well
as an increasing number of other other
infections and and chronic conditions
moving to the integration of
next-generation sequence into clinical
settings putting aside for a minute the
complexity of next-generation sequencing
it's essentially another clinical
laboratory test that includes initial
component of test development and
optimization that's followed by a
validation validation is the component
of the process in which one defines the
performance specifications and the
quality control of calibration
procedures with regard to next
generation sequencing although we do the
validation front to back we focus on
three components one is what we call the
platform validation which addresses how
the sequencing machine is operating any
associated performance specifications
and this is independent
of the clinical application the test
validation component addresses the
capability of the test to to provide a
reliable result with respect to the
clinical intent of the test and the ite
pipeline validation component refers to
how the informatics component of the
test is performing to take the raw data
and generate a clinically useful result
once the validation is completed then
the test moves into the patient testing
environment where quality control
procedures are implemented in addition
to processes for independently assessing
the test performance and this is
sometimes referred to an efficiency
testing as alternate assessment but this
is a way of comparing how well your test
is doing compared to testing that is the
similar testing is being offered in
other laboratories if we look at the
workflow a typical workflow of how
next-generation sequencing is integrated
into the clinical environment there is a
laboratory piece of this and there's a
there's a clinical component if we look
within the laboratory we can further
breakdown the method into how the
patient sample the patient specimen is
processed and then how the data that's
generated initially from processing the
patient sample is further processed so
once the patient specimen is received
from the laboratory DNA is prepared it
may be extract it may be generated using
techniques such as rt-pcr a library of
fragments given sizes is prepared this
library may may may reflect the
composition of an entire human or
pathogen oh or it may reflect the exome
or a defined set of genes a gene
panel sequencing is then performed
through a sequencing instrument and the
output of the instrument is a data file
that contains the sequence data in
itself we can't use that to derive
what's clinically meaningful to report
we have to move to the second stage of
the analysis which is the informatics
pipeline to analyze the output from the
sequencing instrument to arrive at a
clinically meaningful result so during
this process the electronic sample so to
speak is quality control so so sequence
reads that don't meet quality criteria
are eliminated longer contiguous
sequence is generated through alignment
against a reference sequence or through
de novo assembly there is then analysis
to determine if for example human DNA is
being analyzed where variants exist if
there is a pathogen infectious disease
agent bacteria being analyzed then
analysis has done to ID that sequence
there's additional laboratory
interpretation and then this is reported
out to the clinical setting in the
clinical setting the data is often
further reviewed in conjunction with
patient data that may or may not be
available to the laboratory this is
particularly important for analysis
hereditary for hereditary diseases with
respect that family history may
influence for example the assignment of
pathogenicity of a particular variant
based on whether the finding is
consistent or not consistent with the
family history of disease and sometimes
this can change the confidence that a
particular assignment on whether a
variant is pathogenic or not may or may
not be accepted and we'll say a few more
bits about this later in the talk most
of the talk we're going to we're going
to discuss assuring quality practices
through the application of regulatory
requirements
and professional guidance so the caveat
to this is that next-generation
sequencing is a complex rapidly evolving
technology that has significant
implications for for patient care
through a whole set of medical
disciplines so we really would like to
have a framework to assure that we are
are we are able to to provide reliable
test results when using this technology
so as of today the majority of clinical
next-generation sequence tests are
considered laboratory developed tests
meaning that you know laboratories will
purchase the sequencing instrument and
will assemble the informatics pipeline
put these together to develop and then
validate the test that is offered for
patient care so there's a lot of
variability in how this is done among
laboratories that said there are a few
instruments and a few tests that have
moved through the FDA process that are
cleared at this time the vast majority
are not but they can still be validated
an offered patient testing through
[Music]
complying with the clinical the CLIA
regulations and and clinically of the
clinical laboratory Improvement
Amendments are were developed to assure
minimal quality standards for clinical
testing in the laboratory in the US so
in the u.s. LD T's are subject to these
regulations and as such they do require
the laboratories to establish the
analytic performance specifications as
well as the control and calibration
procedures so applying the clear
regulations to next generation
sequencing clinical testing has been
challenging due to the novelty and
complexity of the technology and new
paradigms for data analysis so I'm going
to back up a minute
and take a look at what we call the
turtle testing process which is the
description of what happens from the
time that the position selects the test
to the reporting of the test result the
use in the clinical setting to manage
the patient and with regards to next
generation sequencing there are
components of the testing process that
require a little bit extra attention for
example in terms of matching the
clinical question that's asked to the
decision to use next-generation
sequencing is an important consideration
for example the earlier we shared the
publication of the child who presented
with chrome-like syndrome and clinical
testing and Worksop failed to provide a
diagnosis whereas next-generation
sequencing exome sequencing appeared to
be the logical choice to see what might
be bound to that was less clinically
actionable other conditions may not be
amenable to use of next-generation
sequence testing and these are the
considerations when one is thinking
about test selection and where to go the
analysis as you've seen has multiple
steps with the real the new paradigm
there is the informatics component which
is not which is rather novel for
sequencing laboratories in that that
level of analysis has not been something
that laboratories have previously been
challenged with implementing in the past
so the expertise needed to do that and
the quality control steps needing to
assure that the informatics pathway is
operating as
and it requires specialization which is
still being developed and not as common
as we would like with regards to the
growth of next-generation sequencing in
clinical settings with respects to
results reporting and results
interpretation the challenge here is
that one is dealing with a significant
quantity of data that needs to be
distilled to provide a clinically
meaningful result but also to provide
the real limitations that
next-generation sequencing has for
example there can still be variants
within regions targeted for sequencing
that are mr. for a variety of reasons
and these need to be communicated to the
physician that they understand what the
limitations are so they can act
accordingly so we mentioned that the
clear regulations provides guidance for
quality standards for clinical testing
and indeed and the general section of
the CLIA requirements the components
that we mentioned are addressed with
regard to test validation quality
control procedures just ordering result
reporting proficiency testing and
personal competencies but these are all
general requirements and don't don't
prescribe the specifics that are really
needed for someone to implement NGS with
a high reliability of returning a usual
result a greatest note here is there is
no language regarding how to deal with
the informatics processes that are so
important to next-generation sequencing
and as an outcome of this it becomes
even more complex when one realizes that
sometimes the informatics components are
not performed within the clinical lab
some of these are outsourced some of
these are contracted out
to software specialist software
companies that are not your traditional
clinical laboratory settings and there's
not an oversight framework for precisely
how these folks should be operating not
to allude that they are not able to
return high-quality results
it's just something outside at the
present time the realm of our systems of
oversight at the present time the
Centers for medicare/medicaid services
where's Cleo lives together with the FDA
and CMS are discussing how this can be
addressed to assure a robust informatics
process as these tests continue to move
into clinical practice so in about 2010
a group at CDC recognized that
next-generation sequencing was a rapidly
evolving clinical application and there
at that time there was really no no no
guidance to help laboratories new NGS
into into their clinical settings so we
develop three sequential work groups
that develop guidance to help
laboratories understand what these
consensus workgroups thought were the
important principles to consider when
implementing next-generation sequencing
into clinical clinical settings and we
addressed the in the first guidance we
addressed the the broad elements dealing
with validation and quality control and
reference materials the second focused
on the informatics piece and the third
actually focused on a particular data
file the variant file where what's
variant calls are made because it it
into a file and we describes certain
recommendations for standards so that
these files would be useful in in
achieving you
form results and sharing results among
laboratories
more recently the FDA has developed a
set of guidance document that address
infectious disease testing address
germline testing and address the use of
public human genetic variant databases
the reason the third is there is because
using NGS to do sequence analysis one
has to have a means to equate the
sequence findings with something that's
clinically meaningful and the way this
is usually done is to look at look at
both look at databases that may exist
both in terms of the lab but most of the
time external to the lab and standards
for how these databases should be
transparent publicly available and
curated the principles are described in
this third FDA guidance that is listed
on this slide so since many professional
groups professional organizations have
developed their their own guidance and
many of the principles that are
described in each of these efforts are
really harmonious with each other so
it's so there's far more guidance and
and resources out there for laboratories
who are moving into this realm of
testing to get information so that a
clinically meaningful and reliable
result can be generated so moving to
more of the specifics when we
established our initial CDC workgroup we
reviewed the regulatory language
particularly with regards to the
performance characteristics that were
listed and we noted that as defined
originally
they were really not applicable to
sequence analysis so the workgroup
proposed some language which which
brought the definitions more in line
with how a laboratory offering sequence
analysis can describe their accuracy
their precision their analytic
sensitivity to analytic specificity in
this original set reportable range and
reference range were meant more for
quantitative type assays so we had to
think a little bit harder in how to
adapt these for next-generation
sequencing and just a comment only
portable range we define this as a
regions of the genome in which sequence
of an acceptable quality can be can be
derived by the laboratory test and this
is particularly important in
consideration that as one sequences
large regions of the genome in some
instances there are sub regions that
don't meet the quality criteria set and
in those cases it's important for the
laboratory to identify that so that they
can either use an orthogonal technique
to fill in the gaps or they can list
that as a limitation on the test when
they report the results of the position
so then the physician can use that
knowledge to determine whether they need
to take additional steps to fill in
those gaps or to use that information in
terms of deciding how to interpret the
results received so quality control
procedures they monitor whether each
component of an assay functions properly
and delivers accurate results and every
step of the next-generation sequencing
process that was described has quality
metrics associated probably the more
common ones is coverage and an
understanding coverage one has to
understand
the the majority of next generation
sequencing tests that are presently made
available are essentially massively
parallel clinical tests meaning that
each base is sequenced multiple times a
single sequence of a base using an NGS
platform has an error rate and an
acceptable error rate associated with it
sequencing multiple times when compiling
the data reduces that error rate the
number of times or the coverage that one
needs to sequence a given you know a
given sequence will depend on the
intended application for example if one
is dealing with a homogeneous sample you
may only need to sequence that region a
few times and and and diamonds varies on
this some guidance will say you need 20
fold or 30 fold to get something that is
its highlight one will receive a highly
competent result if one is dealing with
a low concentration or only with
frequency of a specific sequence with
for example in a mixture of bacteria if
one is trying to derive a genetic
profile from a microbiome or a minimal
residual disease and in analysis for
someone with cancer the the coverage
will then need to be increased so that
you can capture with confidence
confidence the low frequency alleles but
the low frequency sequences quality
score is also something that is often
talked about and that typically refers
to the confidence of a given base call
after filtering and a number of other
processes and that establishes criteria
for keeping or throwing out particular
bases when one does sequence analysis
and that fact that that can be at the
heart to of knowing which sub regions
one is confidently reporting or not
recording following NGS analysis
one of the issues that remains to be
discussed is the need for confirmatory
testing so we're dealing with with a
technique where many of the platforms
today they have a small but measurable
false positive rate that's number one
and number two when one is dealing with
a sequence analysis it's not practical
to be able to validate every possible
outcome so with that in mind what many
labs will do and what is recommended by
many of the professional guidance
documents is to take those that one
finds especially variants in terms of
analysis of human DNA and to confirm the
positives using an orthogonal technique
whether it's a different sequencing
techniques such as Sanger sequencing or
or PCR based technique some labs have
developed very sophisticated and
complete validation processes for
regions that are targeted in their
assays some labs will really do a lot of
validation with hotspots areas where
clinically important findings are most
likely to be determined and those labs
will be able to present extensive data
showing that the detection of variants
with those those regions they will claim
that they're able to be very confident
that those calls are accurate calls
I thought it would be employ motive to
quickly go through a validation example
a validation that was done here at CDC
just to share some of the thinking that
goes into the development of a
validation plan so I'm going to talk
about average nucleotide identity and
this is an NGS based method that
compares the genetic similarity of
shared sequences across the genome of
two strains an unknown query sequence
and a well characterized reference
sequence how this works it aligns and
calculates a percent identical
nucleotides and it's designed to answer
the question are two organisms the same
species and the answer is you know you
want the answer to be yes or no it takes
into consideration mobile genetic
elements that are removed from the
analysis so one can compare strain
specific sequence among or between the
strains that are being the samples that
are being assessed so thinking that goes
into this include tirsty finding what's
the purpose and the scope of the
validation so in this case it was
comparing it was it was validating a new
technique to be used as an ancillary
technique to one that's already been
established so you want to compare what
you're doing to a gold standard if the
gold standard does exist
you need to have controls in this case
validation strains and these were these
were selected based on their taxonomic
diversity and Public Health significance
you need to finalize a reference genome
set who's going to do the validation you
need to define the acceptance criteria
and these are the performance
specifications such as accuracy
sensitivity specificity and precision
that you wish to achieve in addition to
the validation set you need to have
challenge strains this was a subset of
60
the validation strange used to assess
the performance characteristics and as
with other tests you'll need to identify
the equipment you're going to be used
proof of proper maintenance and develop
your SOPs your logs your worksheets and
other written requirements and using
this line of thinking and we were able
at CDC to validate NGS tests for six
species of Campylobacter three species
of Escherichia and six species of
Listeria and there's additional
validations that are going on the power
of this receive EC is that during
outbreak investigations not only can we
use these assays to do strain
identification but we can pass that
along to to clinicians so they can
provide more timely management for their
patients so so this really provides us a
really nice tool that serves both our
Public Health functions as well as
clinical functions another question that
comes comes up when we talk about
validation is when is it necessary to
revalidate and where NGS this is this is
important because you're talking about a
test in which a validation takes a lot
of time and is very costly so we need to
think about this a little bit and we
certainly will need to revalidate when
the tests fundamentally change when
there are new sequences targeted or when
there is a method change that affects
downstream and upstream processes when
the chemistry and software updates that
changes the way the algorithms or the
the chemistry might work we need to
typically reestablish the performance
specification
is through jewelry revalidation in whole
or in part of the method for example if
only the informatics pipeline is altered
it may not be necessary to revalidate
the wet lab process steps which includes
those steps associated with the
sequencing sequencing machine there
remains unresolved questions for example
when we're talking about informatics
we're talking about software we're
talking also about software updates
we're talking about firmware software
patches firmware updates and when are
these analogous to a reagent law change
in a traditional clinical chemistry test
when we run out of a reagent what we
would typically to is is get a hold of a
new lot and compare and and compare the
result achieved with what we found with
the old lot as a quality control step
and that was all that it what is usually
needed to be be done so the question
here is when there is a patch or a
firmware update how do we know if that
update or patch was designed just to
make a soccer more efficient or if it's
fundamentally changing the method and we
don't really have a means or process to
do that today it's something that still
needs to be developed but nonetheless
it's still contingent on the
laboratories to understand and to take
ownership of when these patches or
updates occur so they can ask the
question and take the responsible step
to determine whether a quality control
step or a partial or whole revalidation
needs to be performed
so reference materials are important for
all clinical tests for their development
for their quality control for
proficiency testing and for next
generation sequencing there are three
flavors of quality control materials
that one typically thinks about their
genomic DNA that can be derived from
either patient samples or cell lines and
other cases these would need to be
characterized patient samples are good
in the sense that these more closely
mimic the sample that one will be
testing in a laboratory however they're
not they're not going to be constantly
renewable cell line DNA can be renewable
but then we have to think about the
increased possibility that cell line DNA
can have rearrangements mutations or
loss of loss of DNA synthetic DNA allows
us to engineer in a broad range of
sequences and various to target it or
how we wish to use it in a given assay
the downside it doesn't represent the
complexity of a genome it has been used
in spiked in studies you know with some
successes and sometimes less successful
electronic reference data files are
useful for interrogating the informatics
pipeline and these can be engineered to
test the limits of the informatics
pipeline the capability you know to pick
up a variety of variants and again in a
variety of genomic back realms one of
the limitations is that there are a
multitude of data file formats that
currently used so a given set of data
files may not be readily useful for the
different types of software that are
currently
being integrated into aromatic pipelines
and practice so National Institutes of
Standards and Technology for a number of
years have recognized these challenges
and have been involved in efforts to
characterize materials and provide these
for use to researchers to clinical
laboratories and presently there are a
few human genomic human and genomic
human and bacterial genomes available
that have been characterized by NIST
it would be nice to have you know far
more available and additional ones are
being developed the development of these
though as one might imagine are not
trivial and you know what is available
has been very helpful in terms of being
able to assess the performance of one
assay although not necessarily
specifically for the intended clinical
application
so one of the requirements under CLIA
and generally considered good laboratory
practice is moving through the process
to do an independent assessment of test
performance and and this this raises
several questions and challenges so one
of the questions initially raised it
should these challenges be targeted to
specific diseases or clinical
applications that a given NGS test is
designed to provide you know versus the
versus the potential for a methods based
approach in which you don't target a
specific condition but you provide a
material that is generally able to
assess the performance of your NGS
method and the the professionally
testing programs that are available are
still evolving and essentially there's a
combination of approaches that are taken
in some cases materials either human or
infectious disease DNA are provided and
then the lab is a sequence or a targeted
region of those particular samples and
results reported the results are clearly
only going to reflect the smallest of
capability of what any NGS platform is
able to detect but it provides some
measure of how well labs are able to
jointly to detect certain variants or ID
certainly certain infectious infectious
agents at the present time there are at
least three programs offering
proficiency testing the College of
American Pathologists the global
microbial identifier proficiency test
and the European molecular quality
on network some of these programs will
also provide an addition or in place of
the wet method is to provide data files
and then the challenge is for the
laboratory to put those sequence data
through their informatics pipeline to
generate a result which is they reported
and compared among laboratories so I'm
going to complete the talk by saying a
few words regarding generating a
clinically meaningful result and this
diagram was developed in reference to
the sequencing of human DNA and I want
to make two points here one is that
doing each part of the process on the
right hand side you'll see that there
are data files generated that content
gained the outcome from various
components of the analysis the file to
focus on here is the variant file and
this is where in this file this is where
variants that are detected in the
analysis of human DNA are deposit and
then subsequently analysis and
subsequently analyzed to identify those
variants that are clinically meaningful
to report and the way this is done is to
annotate the variants with certain
properties such as their reported
prevalence they reported association
with clinical conditions
their likelihood of interfering with
protein structure and function and many
other attributes in a way at arriving at
which ones would have
clinical impact and to do this as
mentioned both internal and external
databases are utilized to do these types
of annotations you know after which
there is further interpretation that
makes comment regarding the clinical
relevance of the of the findings so with
regards to databases database there are
databases that that contain both human
and clinical Public Health micro
associated sequences one of the
challenges is that many of these
databases were developed to support
research not clinical applications so
where the majority of them the curation
is minimal with regards to databases
that are available with your going to
for human sequences one to particularly
point out is clinvar which is a database
that was developed by NCBI
under NIH that contains curated data
that that makes makes genotype-phenotype
correlations as well as provides other
annotations associated with a given
given sequence given variants in the
clinical in the micro world the FDA is
developing the FDA Argos database which
is being developed to contain highly
curated what they call regular grade
microbial sequences that one can use for
a variety of purposes at particularly
relevant for clinical applications at
the present time there's only a few
hundred sequences that have been
deposited
I said within this resource or sequences
I should say associated with a few
hundred organisms the initial target is
two thousand the global microbial
identifier initiative actually links a
number of international databases just
making those databases available to
available to those who wish to access
those that way CDC has a microbiome net
which primarily contains 16s RNA for
bacteria and fungi that you know is
available for both kinds of analyses
that we talked to
although 16s RNA sequencing it's
probably not the major type of
sequencing that is commonly done using
using this and then we have the
international attack sequence database
which is actually a collaboration
between the Europeans the US and the
Japanese sequence databases and what
they do is they promote uniformity and
transparency in terms of how data is
deposited and made available so I
mentioned with regard to the analysis of
human DNA
once a clinic once once variants are
found that are thought to be clinically
relevant there they're further
classified in terms of to what extent
they may or may not be be relevant so
with regard to germline and somatic
variants that are found several
professional organizations the American
College of medical genetics the
Association promote the pathology they
too have developed a classification
scheme for both Durham line and
analysis that assign pathologic or
likelihood have had association with
with Missa tee or clinical significance
with regard to germline and somatic
variants and the assignment is based on
a number of factors with regard to
assignment for germline variants the ACM
D and Association ology have developed
an algorithm that allows labs to apply
that leads to differentiating variants
according to the classification
described here with regards to whether
they're pathologic likely pathologic
likely benign benign or variants of
unknown significance there are
nonetheless there are interpretative
issues that remain for example even
though we mentioned that the clinvar
contains data that is curated not all
data that is that is provided by
clinical laboratories is an agreement so
quaint lore has developed a
collaborative process to help
laboratories resolve differences and
submissions and interesting way even
though they have a process that has been
reported to reduce the differences that
are reported in the manuscript that is
listed here there still remains perhaps
as much as 12% submissions in which
these differences have not been resolved
there's also been a study with regards
to the application of the interpretation
guidelines in assigning pathogenicity
with regards to the analysis of human
DNA using NGS and other sequencing
methods and you know there was variation
that vary depending what was looking at
but nonetheless the variation could be
could be quite significant and I believe
it was 30 plus percent at times they
were recommendation given for how that
might be reduced but some of the
differences can be attributable to use
of different data sets in annotating the
variants that were then used to make the
assignments in addition another funding
was application of the guidelines appear
to vary among laboratories to address
this additional work was done to develop
what is referred to as the Klingon
pathogenicity calculator which is a
configurable system for assisting
pathogenicity
variants through software and initial
data shows that using this the
variability and assignment was indeed
decreased however there was still
variability in assignment come on
laboratories again the thinking is that
this might be attributed to the input
data that laboratories uses the
databases that are utilized and an
individual laboratories interpretation
of you know which data is most reliable
in terms of making those pathogen acity
assignments
so prior to summarizing some of the high
points of the talk I just wanted to come
back to a slide taken from the
manuscript that reported the child with
chrome-like disease in which exome
analysis was used to find the disease
associated variant leading to transplant
and what's in what's important here is
to note that
xswim analysis initially produced 16,000
there were 16,000 very high confident
variants and the challenge was to reduce
these to the single finding and this
really exemplifies the power that the
current methods provide us in being able
to to sequence and analyze that sequence
to come up with something clinically
meaningful so the high points just to
complete include recognizing that NGS
applications have significant
implications for making diagnosis you
know identifying pathogens that can
really impact impact patient care in
ways that previous methods were not able
to to accomplish informatics is a new
paradigm for everyone the informatics is
who work in or with laboratory
professionals are literally trained on
the job
we don't have an established curriculum
for training these folks today we have a
few people who develop the technologies
and have shared their wisdom with others
and for the most part this is something
that one learns learns learns on the job
although there are discussions to create
a more structured approach
to training for the informatics
components associated with
next-generation sequencing there's a
continuous need for active engagement of
regulatory of professional groups with
in in advancing guidance and other
resources alpha laboratories and
clinicians in using and leveraging
next-generation sequence with the caveat
that this technology is rapidly evolving
our understanding of the genome whether
human or pathogen continue to evolve and
I mentioned that the significant
informatics piece within the clinical
environment but there is also an equal
need on the clinical clinical side with
guidance decision support tools and
education needed to be provided to
healthcare providers to clinicians to
really better understand the power of
next-generation sequence what it can do
what it can't do and and when it is
useful to consider and went in is not
not useful to consider one paradigm for
example is is achieves in Pediatrics in
which in many an increasing number of
centers kids that are recognized with
heritable conditions early on that don't
appear to be diagnoseable using using
conventional means are provided the
opportunity for
exome sequencing early in the diagnostic
cycle as a means to achieve more timely
diagnosis of the condition and some
institutions it's reported that this is
this is resulted in as high as a 40
percent hit rate which is is pretty
pretty significant in the press
clinical systems in clinical diagnosis
for disease that are very difficult to
diagnose so I want to thank everyone for
the opportunity to present and I'm
available for questions
thank you dr. IRA Louvin for that
informative presentation we will now
start to lock you in a portion of the
webinar if you have a question we'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the green crew and I button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is you mentioned the reporting
of secondary findings that some labs
reports when genomic sequencing is
performed is this now standard practice
our patients given a choice in receiving
such results
so so excellent question so when the
percent of recommendations from the
American College of medical genetics was
published this facilitated a lot of
debate within the broader community in
terms you know what is the patient's
right to receive on to receive or have
the decision to receive you know
secondary findings and so the so the the
present set of recommendation reminds
and recommends that prior to testing
that genetic counseling be provided to
fully inform the patient that secondary
findings are available to provide them
the opportunity to opt out it's it's not
a requirement and practices vary among
settings and the consensus appears to be
at this point that genetic counseling
with the opportunity to opt out seems to
be the the majority means by which
secondary findings are handled and
clinical practice
thank you for that answer our next
question is sequence analysis can detect
rare variants or bacterial signature not
directly assessed during the initial
validation of the NGS method can you
provide additional detail regarding how
controls are utilized to validate these
methods in addition is there any
discussion within the FDA we guidance
regarding use of these types of athletes
and the detection bacterial signatures
that were not assessed during method
development so the FDA the FDA guidance
on infectious diseases that I described
early in a talk does have a section that
describes agnostic testing in which a
test you know the test can be performed
in which the strain that's identified
may not have been specifically looked at
during the course of development of the
test
general guidance is given on how to to
deal with this particularly what the
guidance alludes to is having metrics in
place that assure that high quality
sequence can be generated and the use of
curated high quality databases and you
for comparing need to derive information
regarding what the potential ID of that
sequence might be so it's a combination
of being able to demonstrate high
quality sequence essentially
agnostically together with the use of
high quality databases in in being able
to assign signatures to specific
bacterial virus or other other
microorganisms as might be the case
it looks like we're out of time I would
like to once again thank dr. IRA Louvin
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I'm going to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February of
2018 viewers even email from Laverton
you know when this webcast will be
available to read life please share that
announcements with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye